une vaste battue a commencé dans les
montagnes qui dominent le monastère
c'est ici que les commandos du groupe
islamique armé ont enlevé les sept
religieux français il aurait été conduit
dans l'une des caches que les islamistes
possède ici les membres du gia dont la
des chefs étaient blessés avaient besoin
d'un médecin
le père paul dort chez qui soignait les
combattants pendant la guerre
d'indépendance et l europe
les deux moines qui ont échappé à
l'enlèvement devait regagner alger ce
soir malgré l'assassinât de sang neuf
étrangers quelques 300 religieux ont
décidé de rester comme le père lafitte
qui vit ici depuis trente ans des
questions de ma famille j'ai répondait
souvent que c'est pas au moment où
quelqu'un est malade qu'on lui lâche la
main on reste avec et au jeu creux des
j'ai connu des moments très heureux ici
les vents sont plus difficiles et je
compte bien et continuer à partager ces
moments là avec mes amis l'émotion reste
grande chez les moines de l'abbaye
d'aiguebelle qui ne croyait pas aux
enlèvements
ces deux là qu'était partie le père
supérieur christian de chergé arrêter
avec les six autres religieux du
monastère de tibéhirine
ils sont dans une population au milieu
des populations de gens qui subissent le
régime actuel et elle ne voulait pas
quitter cette population à laquelle ses
frères il est très attaché notamment
parce que l'un d'eux devait plus de 50
ans était médecin est quand médecins et
aux services à vocation locale
l'enlèvement du frère médecin n'explique
pas celui des six autres moines sauf si
les groupes islamiques armés ont décidé
de supprimer toute présence chrétienne
dans cette région d'algérie
[Musique]